[Musique]
bonsoir mardi 8 septembre bienvenue dans
le journal de la rédaction de tv 60,18
voici les titres de l'actualité locale
la crise sanitaire qui a frappé la
france s'est muée en crise économique
pour randy gay la récession et lutter
contre le chômage le gouvernement a
annoncé la semaine dernière les grands
axes de son plan de relance 100
milliards d'euros ils seront alloués
réaction avec les élus et entreprises du
département
le phénomène touche la france entière
cent cinquante trois enquêtes sont en
cours pour des faits de multi lation de
chevaux pour prévenir et contrer le
phénomène la mobilisation s'organise sur
le territoire yvelinois ou cinq cas sont
avérés depuis avril elles reportage
auprès des centres équestres et avec la
gendarmerie nationale
enfin notre page dédiée à la législative
partielle dans la 12e circonscription
des yvelines premier tour le dimanche 20
septembre
ils sont onze candidats pour le scrutin
parmi eux le maire de bois d'arcy
philippe benassaya qui est notre invité
et nous reviendrons aussi sur le congrès
de rentrée du parti l est républicain
c'était vendredi et samedi dernier au
port marly
mais avant de développer ces titres le
qu'ovide 19 qui perturbe le début
d'année scolaire depuis hier et deux
classes sont fermées au groupe scolaire
les pépinières de voisins-le-bretonneux
l'une en maternelle l'autre en
élémentaire et décision prise par
l'éducation nationale l agence régionale
de santé après que deux enfants aient
été testés positifs au coronavirus et
les institutrices et l'atsem des deux
classes sont également été placés à
l'isolément
la municipalité a par ailleurs
communiqué aujourd'hui sur la fermeture
d'une troisième classe cette fois ci à
l'école maternelle des à quarante
arpents aux derniers chiffres remontant
à hier soir l'académie de versailles
recensait une école et 13 classes
fermées elle nous vous en parlions hier
un grand dépistage se tient en ce moment
au vélodrome national de saint quentin
en yvelines c'est jusqu'à demain lé test
sont destinés aux salariés travaillant
dans l'agglomération l'opération
organisée en partenariat avec la rs est
gratuite et anonyme
aujourd'hui en moyenne l'équipe réalise
une centaine de tests par heure 80
entreprises se sont inscrites pour une
capacité de 2000 à 3000 tests sur ces
trois jours
premier bilan au micro de justin brasier
et de marie pas de train c'est très
difficile de gérer une entreprise
c'est comme on a eu des demandes aussi
d'autres catégories
on a aussi nos collaborateurs dans nos
mairies voyez mission les fait tous se
passer c'est pareil on fait sauter le
chiffre dont il faut doser
c'est pas simple mais on apprend et je
pense que la prochaine opération elle
sera encore mieux
elle portera encore plus certainement
massivement sur un nombre élevé elle
sera peut être étendue au-delà des
salariés de l'entreprise de saint
quentin
[Musique]
son annonce était très attendu en la
semaine dernière après un report en août
dernier le plan de relance du
gouvernement l'a pour endiguer la crise
économique a été dévoilée le 3 septembre
on en parle avec mélanie poquet bonsoir
ou sein de la rédaction de tv 78 70
mesures pour ce plan et dans les
yvelines comme partout ailleurs
autant dire que l'on a suivi avec
attention les annonces de jean castex le
premier ministre oui ce plan baptisé
france relance c est 100 milliards
d'euros avec trois grands axes la
priorité pour le gouvernement c'est
l'emploi des jeunes il ya une aide de
4000 euros déjà mises en place cela
concerne aussi la formation dans les
métiers et les filières de demain dont
le numérique un domaine chère à saint
quentin en yvelines un mot de jean
michel fourgous vous rappelle que demain
la sécurité sera meilleure dans les
villes qui rend une copie numérique la
l'éducation idem pour la santé et vous
vous allez voir tout les pros tous les
process qui aurait pour votre santé
ils dépendront du numérique donc il faut
bien entendu que demain on est des
réseaux de qualité et on est une culture
élevé autre pilier de ce plan de relance
mais l'anis le réarmement industriels et
oui là ce sont 35 milliards d'euros qui
sont consacrés aux entreprises les tpe
pme vont voir baisser leurs impôts de
production dès le 1er janvier 2021 32 %
des tpe et des pme françaises seraient
bénéficiaires
thomas godefroy scola et président de la
confédération des pme des événements et
nous explique sont intactes toutes les
aides sont très bien et sont les
bienvenus
ce qu'il faut qu'on arrive à faire
maintenant c'est relancer des carnets de
commandes puisque être aidés c'est bien
avoir du travail c'est encore mieux
les troisième axe mélanie c'est la
transition écologique près de 7
milliards d'euros
être dédié à la rénovation énergétique
des bâtiments avec aussi une prime
rénove alors elle a été lancée en
janvier 2020 mais la nouveauté annoncée
en septembre elle sera accessible à tous
revenus modestes intermédiaires et
supérieurs au 1er janvier 2021
quelques précisions de l'alec sky c'est
un dispositif qui vous donne accès au
maximum une aide de 20 mille euros sur
cinq ans par logement est la grande
nouveauté de ces annonces c'est que
c'est une aide qui pourra faire l'objet
d'une bonification lorsque les projets
de travaux sont ambitieux alors pour
plus d'informations sur cette prime le
site concerné ma prime rénove point
gouv.fr un plan de relance qui concerne
grégory bien sûr d'autres volets pour la
culture notamment ce sont deux milliards
d'euros merci mélanie pour toutes ces
précisions dans l'actualité à présent ce
phénomène malheureux dont les
motivations restent pour l'heure un
grand mystère les mutilations envers les
équidés se multiplient en france et les
yvelines n'échappe pas au phénomène face
à ces attaques propriétaire et forces de
l'ordre se mobilisent
le reportage d'astrid bergère et de
marie pas neutre à dans les yvelines
cinq cas ont été recensés depuis le mois
d'avril inquiets les propriétaires
d'équidés met tout en oeuvre pour
protéger leurs chevaux et leurs
structures d'éventuels les attaquent la
partie écuries étaient déjà sécurisé
avec des caméras remet et aujourd'hui on
va essayer de remettre des caméras de re
sécuriser la partie
prairie la partie qui est la plus la
plus vulnérable au jour d'aujourd'hui
et en ce moment on a un maître chien
vizille une société de gardiennage qui
viennent toutes les nuits surveiller les
prix et le poney club
un dispositif essentiel pour le
directeur des écuries mais qui a un coût
c'est un
un surcoût énorme pour les écuries mais
on veut rassurer nos clients on a des
chevaux de propriétaires on a les
chevaux du poney club des enfants qui
viennent toutes les semaines il faut
pour la rentrée puis se retrouver tous
les poneys qui connaissent les groupes
facebook fermé ont aussi été créés ils
permettent de signaler tout comportement
suspect aux abords des centres équestres
et des prix dans les yvelines
deux cavaliers de la garde républicaine
ont notamment pour mission de faire de
la prévention auprès des équipes tant il
les appelle à ne pas se faire justice
eux mêmes la solution c'est plutôt vers
le 17 pour vous préserver de l'agression
faire de 17 et prendre un maximum de
renseignements à visuellement en une
plaque d'immatriculation ne pas rentrer
en contact avec cette personne
les gendarmes ont multiplié leurs
services tournés vers le monde de
l'équitation
nous renforçons le contact auprès des
éleveurs des différents centres
équestres mais aussi des différents et
qui tend afin de leur devenir une
conduite à suivre mais aussi les
rassurer au maximum afin de d'éviter
qu'ils qu'ils paniquent quoi qu'il en
soit quinze mille chevaux et 800
propriétaires vivent dans les yvelines
la gendarmerie les invite à se
manifester pour se faire enregistrer
dans leur base de données
[Musique]
page politique on parle dans un instant
de la législative partielle dans la 11e
circonscription mais d'abord cette
rentrée pour le party les républicains
le week-end dernier au port marly élus
jeunes et militants se sont rassemblés
pour lancer la reconstruction et aussi
préparer les prochaines échéances
électorales retour sur le rendez-vous
avec patrick jacques de dixmude et
nicolas landry qui sera le candidat des
républicains pour la présidentielle de
2000 22 là n'était pas la question de ce
rendez vous de la jeunesse l air au
port-marly la rentrée politique du parti
organisé autour des fédérations jeunes
ça fait presque cinq ans que je milite
pour le parti et j'avais jamais vu
autant de jeunes réunis au même endroit
à la fin de l'été on a pu parler en
toute ouverture de décroissance ou pas
de l'écologie punitive ou alors écologie
plus incitative écologie économie
autorités europe différentes thématiques
d'ateliers organisés autour des élus et
ténors du parti
si l'objectif n'était pas le choix d'un
candidat les discussions se sont
focalisées sur la reconstruction du
parti et d'un programme pour 2022
ce qu'il faut surtout c'est montrer que
aujourd'hui on peut travailler ensemble
que de mal gré mal gré les digues les
différences et la richesse finalement
des profils qui existe à droite ya un
socle de valeurs communes qui est
important qui est solide et c'est sur ça
qu'il faut travailler mais je pense que
la préparation de 2022 ce sera la
conséquence de ces travaux je trouve
qu'il ya une convergence en fait des
idées alors il ya des nuances
évidemment ici ou là il ya des gens qui
sont plus préoccupés par l'autorité par
les problèmes de justice de police
d'identité nationale et puis d'autres
plus sur l'économie plus sur
l'intégration pressenti pour être
candidat à la présidentielle françois
baroin annoncera sa décision d'ici à la
fin de l'année les prochaines échéances
électorales pour les républicains seront
les départementales et régionales en
bonsoir philippe benassaya sorte maire
de bois d'arcy conseiller départemental
des yvelines également vice-président de
l'agglomération versailles grand parc
vous êtes aussi candidat pour la
législative partielle dans la 12e
circonscription des yvelines en
entendant un instant un mot déjà de
réactions sur le sujet que l'on vient de
voir vous qui êtes l'un des vice
présidents de la fédération ait l'air
dans le département est-ce que la
priorité aujourd'hui comme ça a été dit
c'est reconstruire reconstruire unis on
a pu voir par exemple valérie pécresse
qui a fait partie des personnes qui
ouvrait ce congrès à au port marly
d'abord c'est pas donné à tout le monde
de faire un congrès au port-marly de
jeunes républicains de près de 2000 le
jeune je suis pas sûr qu'il y ait cet
exemple ailleurs ça signifie une chose
malgré la reconstruction nécessaire
c'est que ce parti
quoi qu'on en dise contrairement à ce
qu'on entend et contrairement à ce qu'on
lit
c'est un parti qui est bien structuré
bien situé au centre droit et à droite
dans un pays dont le socle est quand
même globalement à droite on l'a vu lors
des dernières municipales
maintenant sous la vème république il
faut toujours qu'il ya un homme ou une
femme qui représente ses idéaux
présidentielle mais tout ne se passe pas
au tour d'une présidentielle
la vie d'un parti politique c'est des
commissions b rendez vous dès des
présents sur le terrain c'est beaucoup
de choses
maintenant comme je vous le dis si on
doit penser uniquement la présidentielle
il faut reconstruire unis c'est vrai et
je pense que pour en parler on a eu
cette image là puisqu'on avait valérie
pécresse qui est un libre aujourd'hui
plutôt satellite delà des républicains
et puis dont l'accueil a été plutôt
plutôt chaleureux et je pense que c'est
celle à venir à mon avis des
républicains après la reconstruction
parce qu'on a pris quand même une baffe
par moment l'expression européenne on
s'est extrêmement bien ressaisi
aux municipales on a gagné beaucoup de
villes de moyenne comme on dit vingt
mille trente mille habitants en france
maintenant c'est la mise en orbite pour
pour les présidentielles et je pense
qu'on y va je pense qu'on y va
honnêtement alors je le disais vous êtes
aussi candidat en ce moment est en
campagne pour la 11e circonscription des
yvelines une législative partielle se
profile premier tour dimanche 20
septembre prochain aux candidats on va
voir leur nom s'afficher peut-être dans
un instant sont sur la ligne de départ
une élection je le rappelle rendu
nécessaire après la démission de nadia
qui est entrée au gouvernement comme
ministre délégué à la ville pourquoi
après avoir été maire de bois d'arcy
conseiller départemental des villes
pourquoi cette candidature dans la 11e
circonscription de choses la première je
complète ce que vous voulez dire
suite à la nomination de nadia et comme
de la vie mais surtout
son suppléant n'a pas pu monter pour
l'effet des problèmes de mise en examen
une enquête de braver la scène
internationale et ses internationales
donc si le suppléant était monté on n'en
parlerait pas aujourd'hui donc on s'est
retrouvé face à une vacance dans cette
circonscription presque inédite c'est
une situation inédite qu'un député
démissionne pour empêcher son suppléant
de de monter la deuxième chose c'est que
beaucoup plus importante que ce fait
divers malheureux c'est qu'aujourd'hui
je pense en france il faut redonner la
parole aux adducteurs
je pense que la période des députés hors
sol sans ancrage local sans rien je
pense que les français reviennent dessus
je pense honnêtement je le sens je
l'entends j'étais notre expérience de
terrain est nécessaire pour qu'elle est
nécessaire 80 n'est pas forcément fléchi
pour des élections partielles moi je
n'avais pas prévu que nadia el et
devenir ministre en mieux tant mieux
pour elle mais et que sur ces pluies on
ne pouvait pas monter
mais face à cette situation je pense
qu'il faut redonner la parole au terrain
si vous permettez juste une petite
anecdote on l'a vu pendant la crise
sanitaire du coville et au printemps
dernier qui était sur le terrain et qui
a réussi à obtenir des résultats
tangibles si ce sont les collectivités
locales régions départements et communes
donc je pense que ça les français l'ont
vu il ya un avant et un après co-lead
l'assurance sur ça se précise que votre
candidature est sous la bannière la
halle herne et qu'elle est aussi soutenu
par rue des générations terrain est
libre voilà plusieurs formations de
droite et du centre est-ce que ça a été
une décision difficile à prendre
je demande ça parce que liée à la loi
sur le non-cumul des mandats si vous
êtes élu demain député de la 11e
circonscription vous devrez laisser
votre fauteuil de maire est ce que ça
c'est un choix difficile c'est
extrêmement difficile c'est toujours
difficile et c'est un véritable crève
coeur je le dis puisque c'est dommage
que cette loi ne nous permettent pas de
cumuler député maire d'une ville de 15
mille habitants je vous le dis
très très aisément c'est jouable
peut-être député maire d'une ville de
300000 habitants je dis pas mais bon une
ville comme bercy et député je suis
conseiller départemental ça ne pose pas
le d'énormes problèmes
c'est vraiment regrettable maintenant
l'équipe est en place le deuxième mandat
est en place les équipes sont faites en
place il n'y a pas de problème mais
c'est vrai que c'est un crève coeur mais
je pense que le l'occasion est unique
elle est inédite comme je les dis pour
faire monter au parlement à l'assemblée
nationale des élus qui ont obtenu des
résultats sur le terrain et des yeux qui
connaissent la réalité qui connaissent
les gens qui connaissent les projets
locaux les acteurs locaux les
entreprises locales c'est important je
pense que le ce qu'on a eu depuis 2007
avec des résultats au pad et en résultat
c'est pas un juge et on fera le bilan de
dudu de ce mandat législatif plus tard
mais c'est vrai qu'on a des députés qui
sont quand même globalement sol qui ne
connaissent pas trop le terrain il faut
revenir je pense à une organisation
plutôt d'en bas vers le haut et c'est
pour ça que je suis candidat et les
thèmes à apporter à l'assemblée
nationale justement c'est cette
connexion avec le terrain dont vous
parlez avec le terrain qu'à la faire
remonter les bonnes pratiques du terrain
je pense qu'on l'a vu encore une fois
pendant le creux vide
les élus locaux ont eu de bonnes idées
qui ont été reprises ailleurs au niveau
national le pouvoir en place un peu
négligé au début les élus terran puis se
sont enfuis s'est rendu compte que on
obtenait des résultats est très très
remarquable ensuite il y as je dirais
plusieurs thématiques très importante
pour la 3e circonscription la sécurité
l'innovation parce qu'on va reparler du
commercial du futur d'elancourt la
vidéoprotection portés par les
collectivités l'environnement bien sûr
l'innovation de l'école numérique et
bien sûr je mettrais un dernier thème la
liberté je pense que dans notre pays la
liberté est en train de s'éteindre de
plus en plus et il faut des députés des
élus qui redonne cette liberté
d'expression qui est le coeur à mon avis
que des valeurs de notre société
non mais malheureusement pris par le
temps mais vous aurez l'occasion dé
développer toutes ces thématiques
puisque un débat sera organisé entre les
candidats de cette 11e circonscription
merci à philippe benassaya l'ex-maire de
bois d'arcy est candidat je le rappelle
l air candidats udi génération terrain
et aussi à libre pour cette 11e
circonscription des yvelines premier
tour le
20 septembre autre candidat justement
sur la ligne de départ olivier galland
qui représente le parti debout la france
présentation avec nicolas landry c'est
le candidat debout la france pour les
élections législative partielle dans la
12e circonscription des yvelines
olivier galland habitants de saint cyr
l'école se lance dans le scrutin
ce père de quatre enfants vit dans la
commune depuis une quinzaine d'années
j'ai commencé à m'impliquer dans la vie
collective avec les associations de
parents d'élèves ça fait 12 ans que je
suis tête de liste sur l'école du
quartier engagé récemment en politique
avec des convictions proche de celle de
nicolas dupont aignan
olivier galland rejoint en 2010 est le
mouvement debout la france il devient
délégué de la 11e circonscription des
yvelines avant d'être désigné candidat
pour la prochaine élection sur ce
territoire
on entend les gens quand on quand on va
à leur contact nous dire je ne vote plus
je ne crois plus en la politique
moi je crois le contraire je crois qu'il
faut se battre il faut se battre pour
nos idées pour défendre nos idées pour
présenter nos idées concernant son
programme olivier galon va engager sa
campagne sur trois axes l'autorité de
l'état la lutte contre les trafics de
drogue et la justice sociale on peut
envoyer massivement les forces de
l'ordre dans les quartiers qui en ont
besoin
et derrière il faut que la justice donne
un exemple fort en mettant de réelles
punition de réelles sanctions afin de
dissuader les délinquants de d'agir une
politique sociale avec avec des crèches
pour les personnes qui en ont besoin
avec des logements pour les couples qui
vont avoir des enfants passent à lui dix
candidats sont en lice les électeurs
sont appelés aux urnes pour le premier
tour le dimanche 20 septembre prochain
[Musique]
un mot de sport avec la deuxième édition
de la tremblaysienne dimanche événement
important puisqu'il s'agit de la
première course à pied des yvelines
depuis l'épidémie de coronavirus et le
confinement est le rendez-vous s'est
tenue dimanche au tremblay sur mauldre
au programme deux parcours de 5 et 10 km
une aubaine pour les coureurs étant
donné le peu d'événements sportifs
maintenu les propos recueillis
rassemblés par patrick jacques de
dixmude et bixente n'a rien senti steban
cette année nous avons 110 coureurs au
départ sur les 5 km et 10 km avec par
contre elle un versement total de 80 %
hors département qui viennent de tout le
grand paris va même plus loin
moi ma dernière course au mois de mars
donc juste avant le kobudo effectivement
on le vit comme un comme un événement
sympa on va d'abord prendre du plaisir
non non c'est très bien et c'est bien
mise en place aujourd'hui donc ça va
être ça va être top
le port du masque de la houle et
distanciation sociale ne peuvent pas
être respecté et n'eut donc sur la zone
de départ et après la zone d'arrivée
après le le temps de récupération
nécessaire et réglementaires et puis
culture à mantes-la-jolie samedi dernier
le ballet giselle a été projeté sur
écran géant en plein air une opération
dans le cadre d'une soirée dans le cadre
de l'opération je vais y arriver opéra
d'été qui se déroule en ce moment dans
le département patrick jacques de
dixmude et célia gars de son go
[Musique]
cabriole entre chats et autres
arabesques les habitants de
mantes-la-jolie ont pu découvrir
gratuitement dans le square brieuc stèle
bourgeois le ballet giselle l'opération
opéra d'été en partenariat avec le
département et l'opéra national de paris
permet à neuf communes des yvelines de
pouvoir proposer à ses administrés des
opéras et des ballets classiques
de quoi ramener la culture au coeur des
villes il faut aussi que la culture
aille au plus près des habitants
il ya une demande à mantes sur l'opéra
sur la musique sur un certain nombre de
choses et donc dès qu'on peut le faire
en plein air dans un cadre sympa il faut
pas s'en priver
et l'année dernière ça avait très bien
marché je suis sûr que ce sera une chose
ce soir et ils étaient plus d'une
centaine à découvrir le ballet ce soir
là dans le public beaucoup de familles
j'ai juste vu qu'il y avait de la danse
classique donc mais qui font de la danse
classique je me suis dit ça pourrait
peut-être les intéressés j'espère
l'année dernière j'étais venu enfin
j'avais vu cendrillon là aujourd'hui
c'était très très bien donc je me suis
dit bon gars cette année je vais y aller
aussi pour d'autres c'est une première
il n'avait jamais vu d'opéra ou de balai
avant j c est la première fois que je
venais voir un opéra du coup je me suis
dit pourquoi pas venir parce que j'avais
jamais vu donc probable couvrir quelque
chose de nouveau c'est une très bonne
initiative qui permettent aux gens de
découvrir qu'ils ne connaissent pas ou
qu'il ya des a priori comme moi de ne
pas y aller à l'opéra
une façon peut-être de découvrir et
permis à l'ebita samedis 12 et 19
septembre d'autres opéras et ballets
sont prévus dans différentes villes du
département comme à jouy en josas où
sera diffusée la traviata ou encore aux
clayes-sous-bois avec le lac des cygnes
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]